hello I'm Rebecca s a former title
holder in the Miss and Mrs America
Pageant systems and I'd like to welcome
you to the world of Dr Joel Wallock I'm
one of many who has been gifted with
restored Health as a result of Dr Wall's
research and nutritional products
Millions have heard his message of
health and long life others have heard
his message of nutrition and Longevity
from his syndicated radio show his books
or his 300 plus speaking engagements per
year listen closely and prepare to
achieve your ultimate in good health it
is my privilege to introduce researcher
author lecturer and world-renowned
Authority on Health and Longevity Dr
Joel Wallace
how many of you grew up on a farm or
still work a farm or have anything to do
with livestock I'll tell you what you're
my kind of people because I grew up on a
farm in West St Louis County and we
start out with beef Cales and uh if if
you raise livestock the only way you can
make money is if you raise a lot of your
own feed for those of you don't have
that experience and so we raised our own
corn and we raised our own soybeans and
our own hay and we had a truck come out
from the mill and this truck would come
out from the mill and it would grind up
the corn and the soybeans and the hay
and then we would add sacks of vitamins
minerals trace minerals and we' make
pellets out of it and this is what we
would feed the calves in 6 months time
we'd ship them to Market to be
slaughtered or we'd save back some of
the best ones for oursel we'd knock them
in the head and eat them put it bluntly
and um it always fascinated me as a
teenager that we did that for those
calves and in six months ship them off
to be slaughtered or weed eat them and
we wanted to live to be a hundred years
of age without any aches and pains and
guess what we didn't take any vitamins
or minerals and that bothered me so I
asked my dad I'd say hey Pops how come
you do that for those Cavs you don't do
that for us and he'd give me this good
old Missouri farm wisdom he'd say things
like shut up boy you're getting this
farm fresh food and we hope you
appreciate it and of course I was very
quiet then because I didn't want to miss
out on any meals well then when I went
to school I went to the university
Missouri school of Agriculture and I got
my degree in agriculture I got my major
in animal husbandry in nutrition my
minor was in field crops and soils then
I got into veterinary school as a
freshman Veterinary student I learned
the answer to my question and the answer
is this we know how to prevent and cure
diseases in animals with nutrition and
the reason why we do that is because we
don't have major medical we don't have
hospitalization Blue Cross Blue Shield
we don't have Medicare if you're going
to make money as a farmer you better
know how to do stuff yourself and you
better do it efficiently with feed and
nutrition if if you can to make a long
story short after I got out of
veterinary school I went to Africa for 2
years and I was able to fulfill a
Boyhood dream I was able to be a Frank
Buck for two years and work with Marlon
Perkins many of you will remember him
from the Mutual of Omaha's Wild Kingdom
and he's a great gentleman and after two
years of working with elephants and
rhino people used to ask me are you a
small animal vet or a large animal vet
well I was telling him I'm an extra
large animal vet cuz I worked with
elephants and rhinos well after two
years he sent me a telegram and said
would you come back to the St Louis Zoo
and work with us we need a Wildlife
veterinarian at the zoo for a special
project we were given a 7 and half
million Grant from the National
Institutes of Health and what we need is
a veterinarian who will do autopsies of
animals that die of natural causes in
the zoo oh I was just Overjoyed to do
that and so I came back and and of
course I not only did autopsies for
animals that died in the St Louis Zoo
but the Brookfield Zoo in Chicago the
Bron zoo in New York the National Zoo
the LA Zoo and so forth and my job again
was to do autopsies of animals that died
of natural causes in the zoo and look
for a species of animals that was Ultra
sensitive to pollution this is because
during the early 60s we had just learned
about pollution and ecological problems
and disasters and nobody quite knew what
to do and so I was supposed to find a
species of animals that was extra
sensitive and use them much like we did
the canaries in the mine you know the
old Welsh coal miners used to put a
canary in a little wicker cage and take
it down in the mine mine and if methane
gas or carbon monoxide would leak into
the mine the canary would drop off the
perch and die first and the men knew to
get out before the Mind blew up or they
suffocated again to make a long story
short uh over a period of some 12 years
I did
17,500 autopsies and over 454 species of
animals and 3,000 human beings who lived
in close proximity to zoos and the thing
that I found out was this every animal
and human being who dies of natural
causes dies of a nutritional
deficiency and that fascinated me it
went back took me back to those calves I
said Gee that's fascinating we could
document this at autopsy both chemically
and biochemically and things you saw
with the eye at the autopsy table well
that fascinated me and I wrote
scientific articles I wrote uh eight
multi-author textbooks and one textbook
of my own cost 140 bucks for medical
students and I'm sure the only thing
they do is use them for door stops and
it couldn't get anybody excited I was on
20 uh I was on 1700
newspapers I was in magazines I was in
every Network TV that you can think of
and guess what couldn't get anybody
excited back in the 60s about nutrition
so what I did was went back to school
and became a physician to use everything
I had learned in veterinary school about
nutrition and my human patients and to
no surprise to me it worked I spent 12
years up in Portland orgon in general
practice and um it was very fascinating
what I'm going to share with you tonight
is what I learned over the those 10 12
years using nutrition with my human
patients and if you take home only 10%
it will save you an enormous amount of
unnecessary misery it will save you a
Gob of money and those of you in
Missouri know what that means a Gob
means a lot okay it'll add many helpful
years to your life well you can't do
this you can't get these helpful years
you can't have longivity you can't live
to your genetic potential just falling
off a stump uh you have to do some
things the first thing I have to do is
convince you that it is worth doing
these things I'm going to start out by
convincing you that the genetic
potential for human beings is 120 years
our genetic potential for longevity in
May 11th the oldest living American at
this time and documented through the
Guinness World Book of Records was
Margaret ski she was from Radford
Virginia she died at age
115 and she died of a nutritional
deficiency you can tell that from her
her habitual
she died of the complications of a fall
what did she die from osteoporosis very
good she died of a Calcium deficiency
she had no heart disease no cancer no
diabetes no other infirmities but she
died three weeks after a fall because
she didn't have enough calcium her
daughter said that she had a craving for
sweets until she died and that's a a
disease called Pica we'll talk about
that in a little bit but usually when
you have a craving for chocolate if
you're a chocaholic or a sugarholic that
means that you have a deficient then in
a third world country in Niger in Africa
a chief by the name of Bower at age 126
was eulogized by one of his wives and
she was bragging about him at his death
at age 126 he was still in possession of
all his own teeth okay so you assume
that other faculties are working
too then here's a gentleman uh from
Syria at age of 133 he died in July of
1993 he fathered nine children after the
age of 80 and this meant if you add up
nine months for each child and a year
for breastfeeding for each one and a
year between each one of the children he
was still fathering children after age
of a 100 so there's still hope for you
fellas then those of you who like
science um in November of
1993 those six biospherians came out of
that dome in Arizona they were in there
for two years three couples and they
were supposed to eat the perfect food
and recycle the atmosphere and grow
their own food and whatnot and have no
pollution in their water or air or food
and when they came out they were
examined by medical gerontologists from
UCA University of California Los Angeles
they put all this information their
physical and their blood work and so
forth into the medical computers at UCLA
and the medical computers projected that
they could live to be 165 years old if
they continued to do what they were
doing so all of that just says to you
that there's a there's a possibility you
can live to be 120 and when I grew up on
the farm we could grow 200
bushels of corn per acre and with all
the labor and all the fertilizer and
everything else you did you could make a
profit if you grew 200 bushels per acre
but if you only got a 100 bushels per
acre and put out that same effort and
the same fertilizer cost you'd lose
money and so I want you to think about
it the average lifespan for an American
today is
75.5 the average lifespan for an MD or a
doctor is
58 you want to gain 20 years
statistically just don't go to medical
school
if you want to live to be 120 there's
only two basic things real simple two
things to remember number one you have
to avoid the pitfalls you have to not
step on the landmines I call it and
those of you in the military you know
what that means you do something stupid
like step on one of those things you
kill yourself wastefully or
unnecessarily and of course if you play
Russian Roulette or smoke excessively or
drink excessively or wear a black
sweatsuit and run down the middle of the
highway at 2:00 in the morning you're
going to get struck by a car uh all of
things are fool hearty but it's amazing
how many tens of thousands of people die
in America from doing those stupid
things every year the last thing I will
share with you on that subject of
avoiding the landmines i' suggest very
strongly to you that you avoid going to
doctors and I'm going to back up that
statement which is a pretty strong
statement from Ralph nater's group in
January of
1993 just about a year and a half ago uh
January 13th he put out a news release
based on a three-year study on the
causes of death in American hospitals
and it was 1500 page report this
three-year study and I'm not going to
waste your time or Mine by going over
the whole thing word for word but the
bottom line says a lot quote 300,000
Americans are killed each year in
hospitals alone as a result of medical
negligence unquote I'm going to read
that figure again because it's a huge
figure quote 300,000 Americans are
killed each year in hospitals alone as a
result of medical negligence unquote now
he didn't say Slipped Away quietly out
of neglect in a Conner somewhere while
they're waiting for an x-ray he used the
word killed when you use the word killed
that means there was a procedure the
doctor was doing went wrong somehow that
means that they gave them a wrong
prescription they put a decimal point in
the wrong spot and gave them an
incorrect dosage these people were
killed 300,000 to appreciate how big a
figure that is you have to compare that
with our military losses in Vietnam over
10 years where we lost 56,000 people
over 10 years or in average of only
5,600 a year on a field of battle where
people had guns and artillery and
explosives trying to kill each other and
millions of people poured out into the
streets and protested that war we had
political Anarchy in the last three
years of the war students took over
universities and colleges with guns and
explosives National Guardsman shot
students at Kent State in Ohio we chased
a president out of the presidency for
5,600 military personnel a year and
here's one profession that takes your
tax money in the form of Medicare and
Medicaid and kills 300,000 of us a year
according to Ralph nater and I believe
him he has no ax to grind and you can go
out in the street any day of the week in
any City and there isn't even a crazy
Street Preacher out there with a sign
that says protect us from
doctors I want you to think about that
folks that's number one you have to
avoid stepping on the landmine so
there's a certain value in treating
yourself when you can or preventing
disease so you don't have to get treated
now the second thing you have to do
number two is you have to do the
positive things you have to do the
positive things and I'm going to start
out here by just putting a figure up on
the board it's the number 90 and you
need 90 nutrients in your diet every day
you need 60 minerals you need 16
vitamins you need 12 essential amino
acids or protein building blocks and you
need three essential fatty acids you
need 90 nutrients in your daily diet
otherwise you're going to get a
deficiency disease if you don't have
them in complete numbers and optimal
amounts I can tell you that I was one of
those nerds back when I was in college I
had a clipboard we didn't have computers
back then so I had a clipboard and I I
was one of those funny guys with glasses
and would walk up and down in the
Student Union there in Columbia and say
do you take vitamins and minerals I was
still fascinated by that and and of
course people kind of look at you crazy
and say well yeah I take vitamin E and
I'd wait for them to come up with the
other 89 and they didn't they just oh I
take vitamin E well today if you ask
people do you take food supplements they
say oh yeah I take Tums
because that's what you know they hear
all the time well again you need 90
nutrients if you're going to make it but
the newspapers know and the magazines
and TV and radio knows that we're
interested in Health and Longevity and
and supplements so they all talk to us
not because the medical profession has
asked them to do that in their stad the
medical profession doesn't say hey we're
so busy saving people with surgery and
chemotherapy and radiation and
pharmaceuticals would you please educate
the people on nutrition they do it
because it sells newspapers well my
favorite article of all time appeared in
Time Magazine April 6th 1992 and if you
haven't read it I'd urge you to get it
out of a school library or public
library and photocopy it stick one copy
on the door in the bathroom and one on
the refrigerator it's a cover article it
says the real power of vitamins new
research shows they may help fight
cancer heart disease and the ravages of
Aging again there's six positive pages
in here there's only one negative
sentence and was issued by a medical
doctor who was asked by the writer of
the article what do you think think
about vitamins and minerals for people
as food supplements and here's what the
doctor said quote popping vitamins
doesn't do you any good sniffs Dr Victor
Herbert a professor of medicine at New
York City's Mount Sinai Medical School
we get all the vitamins we need in our
diets and taking supplements just gives
you expensive urine unquote well to give
you a Missouri translation of that that
means you're just peeing away your
dollars if you take vitamins and
minerals you might as well W up your
dollars and throw them in the toilet and
flush them away cuz you're not getting
any redeeming value from it those quacks
are just taking your money for those
vitamins and minerals that's what he was
trying to say got published so it must
be true right after having done those
17,500 autopsies and 454 species of
animals from around the world and 3,000
humans and liking to be healthy myself
and having children and grandchildren
and not too distant future children I'd
rather pee out 50 cents or a dollar a
day worth of excess vitamins and
minerals it's prettyy cheap insurance if
you don't invest in yourself to the tune
of a buck a day for vitamins and
minerals guess what you're going to
invest in the lifestyle of an MD
somewhere because when you pay the
medical doctor your fee for going to see
him not one penny of that goes to study
how to diagnose or treat or prevent a
catastrophic disease in a little child
like who was in here earlier or how to
prevent or diagnose or treat better
breast cancer prostate cancer and adults
guess what that money goes for pays the
doctor's mortgage makes his Mercedes
payment it pays a tuition for his kids
to go to medical school at havid you
know where havid is up in Baston pays a
tuition for his kids to go to law school
at Yale between 1776 and the second
world war the US government spent $80
million on Healthcare and Health Care
research and studies right now we're at
$1.2 trillion a year for healthc care
and it's free we all know it's free
right it's not free but we're supposed
to believe it's free and everybody wants
more of it and more free stuff I'll tell
you what if we used a human type medical
system for the agricultural industry and
the livestock your hamburger cost $275 a
pound on the other hand if you use the
agricultural health system that we use
in animals for humans your monthly
insurance premiums for a family of five
would be $10 a month you take your
choice well I believe since we've made
them wealthy through insurance program
and government subsidies I believe they
owe us something I believe they owe us
at least as much as the industries do
according to for instance recall notices
this was started of course I don't know
25 years ago when Ralph nater learned
that the Ford Motor Company had made a
pinto car with a rear end gas tank that
would blow up when you got hit from
behind at 20 M hour fry everybody in the
car and when people complained to Ford
Motor Company they said well you're just
dumb for getting in a car accident we're
not going to pay you for that Ralph
nater says no it's a faulty design so he
went to a federal court and the judge
agreed with him and through a court
order forced Ford Motor Company to send
everybody a uh recall notice with a
registered letter bring that car in and
they'll fix it for nothing but they kill
300,000 a year and nobody protest as
long as we get ours free and that scares
me that attitude at any rate I've got a
bunch of these recall notices you should
have gotten over the last couple years
we'll go through them quickly number one
is ulcers how many of you ever heard
that ulcers is caused by stress
okay everybody's heard that if you don't
raise your hand you got Alzheimer's or
your fibon
right well we knew 50 years ago and in
the veterinary industry that ulcers at
least in pigs was caused by a bacteria
called helicobactor pylori and of course
we couldn't get one of these high-priced
stomach surgeons from Mayo Clinic in
fact we always used to yell hold the
Mayo when they'd say stuff like that
otherwise your pork chops would be $275
a pound to pay for that kind of surgery
and we learned that with a trace mineral
called bismuth and the tetracycline
antibiotic that we could prevent and and
cure those stomach ulcers and pigs
without surgery and so that's what we
did cost five bucks to cure a pig of
stomach ulcers with bismuth the trace
mineral and tetracycline well the
National Institutes of Health now not
the national Inquirer but the National
Institutes of Health came out in
February 1994 and said ulcers are caused
by a bacteria called helicobactor pylori
not stress and they can be cured they
actually use the Cure word in this news
release medical researchers never do do
that they always say it shows promising
results or may be beneficial they use
the Cure word National Institutes of
Health and they say can be cured with a
combination of the trace mineral bismuth
and Tetra cycling well for those of you
who don't know what bismo comes in you
can get it from any grocery store or
drugstore it's pink about 295 for an 8
ooun bottle and it's called Pepto Bismol
so a teaspoon a day full of Pepto Bismol
and some rmis and calf scour pellets you
can take care of ulcers now you have
your choice where you're going to treat
your own for five bucks or go get
Whitted on that's your choice then
what's the number two cause of death in
Americans terrible disease called cancer
right now when doctors get information
on cancer you'd think they'd photocopy
that and when they send you that bill
they should send you some photocopies of
this stuff well in September of 1993 the
um National Cancer Institute not the
national Inquirer but the National
Cancer Institute and the um havid
Medical School up in Baston did a study
on cancer Pat and they came out and they
said an anti-cancer diet was found well
at any rate they picked China to do this
study because in one Province henan
Province in China they have the highest
rate of cancer in the whole world they
took 29,000 people for 5 years in this
study and what they did was give them
different vitamins and minerals at
Double the recommended daily allowance
for Americans now that's a trivial
amount for instance they use vitamin C
for one group and of course the um RDA
recommended daily allowance for vitamin
C is 60 Mig double thats can be 120
milligram you can't go into a health
food store and find a vitamin C tablet
or capsule for less than 500 milligrams
for an adult and of course lonus Pauling
the gentleman with two Nobel prizes says
if you want to prevent and treat cancer
with vitamin C you got to use 10,000
milligrams a day well all the doctors
who used to argue with him back 35 years
ago were all dead and today lonus
Pauling still 994 and he works 14 hours
a day s days a week on his Ranch in the
Big Sir in California and teaches at the
University California San Francisco so
you have to make up your choice whether
you're going to listen to the Dead
Doctors or lonus Pauling your choice
okay vitamin C double the RDA nothing
happened vitamin A Double the RDA
nothing happened zinc riboflavin the
trace mineral mbum niin nothing happened
in one group they got a major benefit in
this group they got three nutrients at
one time they got vitamin E they got
beta katene and the trace mineral
selenium that those three were at Double
the RDA and if you get a half a percent
benefit in any nut nutritional or
pharmaceutical experiment you've made a
major Improvement in Humanity's life and
so these articles get published so I
want you to remember that statistic a
half a percent is major benefit well in
this group that received the vitamin E
beta keratin and selenium for 5 years
deaths from all causes were reduced by
9% almost 10 out of every hundred or one
out of every 10 who were going to die in
that 5 Years From Any cause
survived then cancers all cancers 133%
survived who would have died without
those three
nutrients so 13 out of 100 lived who
would have died and then the type of
cancer that was most prevalent in henan
Province stomach and esophageal cancer
21% lived who would have died 21 out of
100 lived now to me those are
significant numbers and your physician
for the number two cause of death in
America should have sent every one of
you a photocopy of that at least giv you
information even if he doesn't want to
give you the advice give you the
information let you make up your own
mind well here's one I think is funny on
one hand and on the other side it tells
you the attitude of Physicians this has
to do with arthritis it was in September
24th 1993 that it was released again it
was from the havit medical school and
the Baston VA Hospital how many of you
in here have ever been to a VA Hospital
anybody in this room okay good well you
know the people who've been to a VA
Hospital you have two opportunities to
give your life for your country once on
the field of battle and the others in
the VA Hospital right well at any rate
the of the release was chicken protein
hals the swelling and pain of arthritis
in a patient trial and what they did
they took people who failed to respond
in any way to medical treatment for
arthritis these people got gold shots
mesot trexate they got aspirin
prednizone cortisone everything else you
can think of physical therapy and the
only thing left for them was joint
replacement surgery okay now before
Harvard Medical School the VA hospital
was going to give it to them they said
look we're looking for some people who
are willing to suffer for 90 more days
just 3 months because we want to try
something a short-term experiment and
they got 29 volunteers and what they did
for those 29 volunteers who failed to
respond in any way to medical treatment
for arthritis was they gave them a
heaping teaspoonful of groundup dried
chicken cartilage in their orange juice
every morning just a heaping teaspoon of
ground up chicken cartilage and in 10
days according to Harvard Medical School
all the pain and inflammation was gone
these are people who didn't respond in
any way to medical
treatment in 30 days they could open up
a new pickle jar that had never been
opened and 90 days 3 months they had
maximum return of function here's the
funny part the funny part comes by a
statement of the guy who was the
director of that study from Harvard
Medical School and here's what he said
quote listen to the words are very
important quote after 3 months it was
clear that the drug was beneficial
unquote because it worked chicken
cartilage had become a
drug you can see he's thinking about
patent numbers and he's are rolling
around with 300 bucks a capsule 20
patients and you can just see him
calculating
right that means if you go to Kentucky
Fried Chicken and you buy a bucket of
chicken throw away the skin and the meat
and eat the ends off the bones you're
practicing medicine without a
license and if you go to a Kentucky
Fried Chicken in the middle of the night
in the dark of the night and you go to
their dumpster and you root through
there and you collect two five gallon
feed buckets full of chicken bones and
you take them home with a hammer and you
pound off the ends of those bones and
dry your own cartilage in the micro wave
you know you're manufacturing
pharmaceutical and the FDA is going to
put you in jail next time I come by here
in 3 months you're going to run up on
this stage and hug me and kiss me if you
got arthritis how many you ever heard of
Alzheimer's disease everybody's heard
about it today 50 years ago when I was a
little kid there's no such thing as
Alzheimer's disease it's a new disease
one of those things that just sort of
happened now it's a major disease one
out of every two people who reach age 70
get Alzheimer's disease pretty scary we
learned 50 years ago in the animal
industry how to prevent and cure in the
early stages Alzheimer's disease and
livestock you imagine how much a farmer
would lose if the pigs were all lay
their scratching their head saying why
am I
here where is the feed box because if
they're not gaining a couple of pounds a
day you're losing money right so we
learned in the agricultural industry how
to prevent and in the early stages cure
Alzheimer's disease and we do it with
high doses of vitamin E and low intakes
of vegetable oil you say wall like
that's crazy high doses of vitamin E
well you should have got a recall notice
from your doctor in July of 1992 because
the University of California I mean
we're talking about a sophisticated
research medical school here University
of California San Diego came out and
said vitamin E eases memory loss in
Alzheimer's victims now they're only 50
years behind on that from veterinary
medicine so it might be safer going to a
veterinarian then how many of you in
this room ever had a kidney stone
anybody in here ever get that kidney
stone okay I see a few in here what's
the first thing a doctor told you to
give up nutrition
when you got your kidney stone give up
calcium no Dairy no Dairy none of those
vitamin mineral things with calcium in
them because they have the stupid naive
ignorant belief that's pretty intense
they have the stupid ignorant naive
belief that the calcium in your kidney
stone comes from the calcium you eat
when in fact it comes from your own
bones when you have a raging Calcium
deficiency a raging osteoporosis then
you get kidney stones we learned years
ago in writing in the agriculture C
industry if you wanted to prevent kidney
stones and livestock you better give
them more calcium you better give them
more magnesium and more Boron now the
reason is of course bulls and rams male
cattle and sheep have special Anatomy
when they get a kidney stone they die
they call water belly they die when you
and I get a kidney stone we just wish we
were dead but no farmer is dumb enough
to pay for the feed for an animal and
have it die before you can either eat it
or send it to Market so we learned how
to prevent those things well you should
have got a recall notice from your
doctor especially you people who've had
kidney stones your you're ol ologist
should have sent a notice to you this
was uh March of 1993 it says calcium
limits kidney stone risk and this is
from the havid medical school up in
Baston by the way in a study that turns
conventional medical wisdom on its head
researchers have found that people whose
diets are rich in calcium run a reduced
risk of developing kidney stones in a
study of more than 45,000 people that
who were ranked into five categories the
group that had the most calcium had no
kidney stones now about 5 years ago when
I started out on this Crusade and
started lecturing to people all across
America and I'm in one time zone and the
next and all over I knew I was going to
get crazy out there uh doing this last
year I was on the road 300 days out of
the Year 300 out of 365 days and so I
decided I needed to have a hobby that I
could take with me every time I get a
little wacko I could go in my room and
do this Hobby and I'd be okay you know
be kind of like having a little piece of
home with me wherever I went and I
wanted to have a hobby that would uh uh
help other people I didn't want to
collect baseball cards cuz I like
football and I didn't want to do just
crossword puzzles because good mental
exercise but wouldn't help anybody else
and um I couldn't take my compost pile I
like the garden and the hotels don't
like that you know so I decided I was
going to collect obituaries of doctors
and
lawyers now as crazy as that sounds
remember I told you the doctors lived to
an average age of 58 and we lived to
75.5 and here's a group of people
professionals who pontificate you and
tell you well this is what you need to
do you need to give up salt and uh no
caffeine and you need to not eat butter
and eat margarine and do all these crazy
things and they die at age 58 on the
average and anyway I got a few of them
here some of my favorites this is Dr
Stuart cartright age 38 he dropped dead
in his home he was a family practitioner
of a ruptured aneurysm that's a
ballooning of an artery that's a
weakened artery because of the
fragmenting or the brittle condition of
the elastic fibers and Aries just like
when you hit a Chuck hole with your car
tire and you break the cords in there
and you get a balloon he dropped dead
like he was pull axed okay right in his
home from a ruptured aneurysm now we
learned in 19 oh I think it was uh
57 aneurysms are caused by a copper
deficiency we had a pilot project
turkeys and we made complete food
pellets where you put all the 90
nutrients in there and in the first 13
weeks fully half of those turkeys died
farmers were out there every morning
picking them up by the bush basket they
took them to the state diagnostic labs
and they autopsy and they found out that
they all had died from a ruptured a
Artic aneurysm so they doubled the
amount of copper in there and the next
year they didn't lose a single turkey
from a ruptured AR Artic aneurysm and
they ran that experiment in mice and
rats and rabbits and dogs and cats and
uh calves and sheep and pigs and whatnot
and guess what they found out that
there's a whole series of diseases that
are caused by a copper deficiency gray
hair is the first sign when you start
getting gray hair regardless of your age
you got a copper defic deficiency you
get skin wrinkles because the elastic
fibers in your skin are going those
little crows feet around your eyes and
facial and body skin wrinkles you look
like you're a little prune drying up
okay then of course there's the um
varicose
veins that's caused by an elastic fiber
breakdown then of course parts of your
body begin to Sag under your arms your
breast your bellies your legs all this
stuff starts sagging and you can go to a
cosmetic surgeon or plastic surgeon if
you want but it's a lot cheaper and a
lot more effective and a lot safer if
you just take some copper Dr cartrite
may have had a medical degree but he
didn't have expensive urine so he died
of something that even a turkey Wouldn't
Die from then here's one this fellow he
was a doctor's doctor Dr Martin Carter
he almost made it he died at age 57 he
got his medical degree from havid
medical school and his PhD in medicine
from Yale he was autopsied by the best
cuz he was a doctor's Doctor Who said
quote the cause of death was a ruptured
a Artic aneurysm said Dr Jules the
Rockefeller University Hospital unquote
what did he die from copper deficiency
see he didn't have expensive urine
either then here's an attorney she was
so famous she was from Detroit age 44
Ellen Joyce alter uh she was in the New
York Times obituary she made the big
time and uh of course she probably had
steel buns because she belonged to one
of those private health clubs all these
gals want steel buns you know doing
their little
exercises but she didn't have expensive
urine because she died of a ruptured
cerebral
aneurysm when they don't do an autopsy
the symptoms could be called a stroke or
uh subdural Hemorrhage but very
frequently they're caused by a ruptured
aneurysm which is a copper deficiency
she didn't have expensive urine how many
of you here have ever heard of a guy by
the name of Stuart Burger Stuart Berger
he he wrote five bestselling books on
health and diets and nutrition he got
his medical degree from tus medical
school which is a very fine medical
school in Boston not too far away from
uh Harvard Medical School and the books
he wrote included the Southampton diet
for weight loss he wrote Forever Young
20 years younger in 20 weeks and how to
be your own nutritionist and he died at
age 40 how'd you like to follow his
dietary practices he died at age 40 of
cardiomyopathy which is a selenium
deficiency the same cause as white
muscle disease or or stiff lamb disease
and any farmer can go to a feed store
and get selenium pellets or selenium
injections things like celotto and Coy
and so forth and Dr Stuart burer a guy
who wrote five best-selling books on
nutrition died of a nutritional
deficiency he didn't have expensive
urine you can prevent totally prevent
cardiomyopathy for 10 cents a day and if
we don't do it we're malignant dumb I
like to call it you're malignant dumb if
you don't take in 10 cents a day worth
of selenium it's a waste of your life
that's one of those landmines you can
avoid the medical treatment of choice
for cardiomyopathy is a heart transplant
cost
$750,000 I want you to think about that
they get the heart free from a donor
they get the blood free for the surgery
from the relatives they use $2.50 worth
of suture material and they charge a
$750,000 for that procedure now 6 months
ago in La when they had the earthquake
they were putting people in jail for 60
and 90 days for price gouging for
selling these terrified people a gallon
of water for
$4 they put them in jail for price
gouging for selling them a gallon of
water for four bucks now to me that's
entrepreneurialism you know that's being
in business for yourself if you had a a
way to distill water and make water and
you had a car and you could get in there
and sell those people a gallon of water
for four bucks hey more power to you
because if you go to a 7-Eleven and buy
a quart of Evan water it's
$129 so four of those quarts is a five
bucks hello I'm Rebecca s a former title
holder in the Miss and Mrs America
Pageant systems and I'd like to welcome
you to the world of Dr Joel wallik I'm
one of many who has been gifted with
restored Health as a result of Dr Wall's
research and nutritional products
Millions have heard his message of
health and long life others have heard
his message of nutrition and Longevity
from his syndicated radio show his books
or his 300 plus speaking engagements per
year listen closely and prep prepare to
achieve your ultimate in good health it
is my privilege to introduce researcher
author lecturer and world-renowned
Authority on Health and Longevity Dr
Joel
[Applause]
Wallace how many of you grew up on a
farm or still work a farm or have
anything to do with livestock I'll tell
you what you're my kind of people
because I grew up on a farm in West St
louisy County and we start out with beef
Cales and uh if if you raise livestock
the only way it can make money is if you
raise a lot of your own feed for those
of you don't have that experience and so
we raised our own corn and we raised our
own soybeans and our own hay and we had
a truck come out from the mill and this
truck would come out from the mill and
it would grind up the corn and the
soybeans and the hay and then we would
add sacks of vitamins minerals trace
minerals and we make pellets out of it
and this is what we would feed the
calves then 6 months time we'd ship them
to Market to be slaughtered or we'd save
back some of the best ones for oursel
we'd knock them in the head and eat them
put it bluntly and um it always
fascinated me as a teenager that we did
that for those calvs and in six months
ship them off to be slaughtered or weed
eat them and we wanted to live to be
hundred years of age without any aches
and pains and guess what we didn't take
any vitamins or minerals and that
bothered me so I asked my dad I'd say
hey Pops how come you do that for those
Cals you don't do that for us
and he'd give me this good old Missouri
farm wisdom he'd say things like shut up
boy you're getting this farm fresh food
and we hope you appreciate it and of
course I was very quiet then because I
didn't want to miss out on any meals
well then when I went to school I went
to the University of Missouri school of
Agriculture and I got my degree in
agriculture I got my major in animal
husbandry and nutrition my minor was in
field crops and soils then I got into
veternary school as a freshman
Veterinary student I learned the answer
to my question and the answer is this we
know how to prevent and cure diseases in
animals with nutrition and the reason
why we do that is because we don't have
major medical we don't have
hospitalization Blue Cross Blue Shield
we don't have Medicare if you're going
to make money as a farmer you better
know how to do stuff yourself and you
better do it efficiently with feed and
nutrition if you can to make a long
story short after I got out of
veterinary school I went to Africa for
two years and I was able to fulfill a
Boyhood dream I was able to be a Frank
Buck for two years and work with Marlon
Perkins many of you will remember him
from the Mutual of Omaha's Wild Kingdom
and he's a great gentleman and after two
years of working with elephants and
rhino people used to ask me are you a
small animal vet or a large animal vet
well I tell them I'm a extra large
animal vet because I worked with
elephants and rhinos well after two
years he sent me a telegram and said
would you come back to the St Louis Zoo
and work with us we need a Wildlife
veterinarian at the zoo for a special
project we were given a $7.5 million
Grant from from the National Institutes
of Health and what we need is a
veterinarian who will do autopsies of
animals that die of natural causes in
the zoo oh I was just Overjoyed to do
that and so I came back and and of
course I not only did autopsies for
animals that died in the St Louis Zoo
but the Brookfield Zoo in Chicago the
Bron zoo in New York the National Zoo
the LA Zoo and so forth and my job again
was to do autopsies of animals that died
of natural causes in the zoo and look
for a species of animals that was Ultra
sensitive to pollution this because
during the early 60s we had just learned
about pollution and ecological problems
and disasters and nobody quite knew what
to do and so I was supposed to find a
species of animals that was extra
sensitive and use them much like we did
the canaries in the mine you the old
Welsh coal miners used to put a canary
in a little wicker cage and take it down
in the mine and if methane gas or carbon
monoxide would leak into the mine the
canary would drop off the perch and die
first and the men knew to get out before
the mine blew up or they suffed ated
again to make a long story short over a
period of some 12 years I did
17,500 autopsies and over 454 species of
animals and 3,000 human beings who lived
in close proximity to zoos and the thing
that I found out was this every animal
and human being who dies of natural
causes dies of a nutritional
deficiency and that fascinated me it
went back took me back to those calves I
said Gee that's fascinating we could
document this at autopsy both chemically
and biochemically and things you saw
with the eye at the autopsy table well
that fascinated me and I wrote
scientific articles I wrote uh eight
multi-author textbooks and one textbook
of my own cost 140 bucks for medical
students and I'm sure the only thing
they do is use them for door stops and
it couldn't get anybody excited I was on
2020 uh I was on 1700
newspapers I was in magazines I was in
every Network TV that you can think of
and guess what couldn't get anybody
excited back in the 60s about nutrition
so what I did was went back to school
and became a physician to use everything
I had learned in veterinary school about
nutrition and my human patients and to
no surprise to me it worked spent 12
years up in Portland Oregon in general
practice and um it was very fascinating
what I'm going to share with you tonight
is what I learned over those 10 12 years
using nutrition with my human patients
and if you take home only 10% it will
save you an enormous amount of
unnecessary AR misery it will save you a
Gob of money and those of you in
Missouri know what that means a Gob
means a lot okay it'll add many helpful
years to your life well you can't do
this you can't get these helpful years
and you can't have longevity you can't
live to your genetic potential just
falling off a stump uh you have to do
some things and the first thing I have
to do is convince you that it is worth
doing these things I'm going to start
out by convincing you that the genetic
potential for human beings is is 120
years our genetic potential for
longevity in May 11th the oldest living
American at this time and documented
through the Guinness World Book of
Records was Margaret ski she was from
Radford Virginia she died at age
115 and she died of a nutritional
deficiency you can tell that from her
her
obituary she died of the complications
of a fall what did she die from
osteoporosis very good she died of a
Calcium deficiency she had no heart
disase disase no cancer no diabetes no
other infirmities but she died 3 weeks
after a fall cuz she didn't have enough
calcium her daughter said that she had a
craving for sweets until she died and
that's a a disease called Pica we'll
talk about that in a little bit but
usually when you have a craving for
chocolate if you're a chocaholic or a
sugarholic that means that you have a
deficiency then in a third world country
in Niger in Africa a chief by the name
of Bower at age 126 was eulogized by one
of his wives and she was bragging about
him him at his death at age 126 he was
still in possession of all his own teeth
okay so you assume that other faculties
are working
too then here's a gentleman uh from
Syria at age 133 he died in July of 1993
heathered nine children after the age of
80 and this meant if you add up nine
months for each child and a year for
breastfeeding for each one and a year
between each one of the children he was
still fathering children after age of a
hundred so there's still hope for you
fellas then those of you who like
science um in November of
1993 those six biospherians came out of
that dome in Arizona they were in there
for two years three couples and they
were supposed to eat the perfect food
and recycle the atmosphere and grow
their own food and whatnot and have no
pollution in their water or air or food
and when they came out they were
examined by medical gerontologists from
UCLA University of California at Los
Angeles they put all this information
their physical and their blood work and
so forth into the medical computers at
UCLA and the medical computers projected
that they could live to be 165 years old
if they continued to do what they were
doing so all of that just says to you
that there's a there's a possibility you
can live to be 120 and when I grew up on
the farm we could grow 200 bushels of
corn per acre and with all the labor and
all the fertilizer and everything else
you did you could make a profit if you
grew 200 bushels per acre but if you
only got 100 bushels per acre and put
out that same effort and the same
fertilizer cost you'd lose
money and so I want you to think about
it the average lifespan for an American
today is
75.5 the average lifespan for an MD or a
doctor is
58 you want to gain 20 years
statistically just don't go to medical
school you want to live to be 120
there's only two basic things it's real
simple two things to remember number one
you have to avoid the pitfalls you have
to not step on the land mine I call it
and those of you in the military you
know what that means you do something
stupid like step on one of those things
you kill yourself wastefully or
unnecessarily and of course if you play
Russian Roulette or smoke excessively or
drink excessively or wear a black
sweatsuit and run down the middle of the
highway at 2:00 in the morning you're
going to get struck by a car uh all of
those things are fool hearty but it's
amazing how many tens of thousands of
people die in America from doing those
stupid things every year the last thing
I will share with you on that subject of
avoiding the landmine i' suggest very
strongly to you that you avoid going to
doctors and I'm going to back up that
statement which is a pretty strong
statement from Ralph naters group in
January of
1993 just about a year and a half ago uh
January 13th he put out a news release
based on a three-year study on the
causes of death in American hospitals
and it was 1500 page report this
three-year study and I'm not going to
waste your time or Mind by going over
the whole thing word for word but the
bottom line says a lot quote 300,000
Americans are killed each year in
hospitals alone as a result of medical
negligence unquote I'm going to read
that figure again because it's a huge
figure quote 300,000 Americans are
killed each year in hospitals alone as a
result of medical negligence unquote now
he didn't say Slipped Away quietly out
of neglect in a corner somewhere while
they're waiting for an x-ray he used the
word killed when you use the word killed
that means there was a procedure the
doctor was doing went wrong somehow that
means that they gave them a wrong
prescription they put a decimal point in
the wrong spot and gave them an
incorrect dosage these people were
killed 300,000 to appreciate how big a
figure that is you have to compare that
with our military losses in Vietnam over
10 years where we lost 56,000 people
over 10 years or an average of only
5,600 a year on a field of battle where
people had guns and artillery and
explosives trying to kill each other and
millions of people poured out into the
streets and protested that war we had
political Anarchy in the last three
years of the war students took over
universities and colleges with guns and
explosives National Guardsman shot
students at Kent State in Ohio we chased
a president out of the presidency for
5,600 military personnel a year and
here's one profession that takes your
tax money in the form of Medicare and
Medicaid and kills 300,000 of us a year
according to Ralph nater and I believe
him he has no acts to grind and you can
go out in the street any day of the week
and any any City and there isn't even a
crazy Street Preacher out there with a
sign that says protect us from
doctors I want you to think about that
folks that's number one you have to
avoid stepping on the landmine so
there's a certain value in treating
yourself when you can are preventing
disease so you don't have to get treated
now the second thing you have to do
number two is you have to do the
positive things you have to do the
positive things and I'm going to start
out here by just putting a figure up on
the board it's the number 90 and you
need 90 nutrients in your diet every day
you need 60 minerals you need 16
vitamins you need 12 essential amino
acids or protein building blocks and you
need three essential fatty acids you
need 90 nutrients in your daily diet
otherwise you're going to get a
deficiency disease if you don't have
them in complete numbers and optimal
amounts I can tell you that I was one of
those nerds back when I was in college I
had a clipboard we didn't have computers
back then so I had a clipboard and I I
was one of those funny guys with glasses
and would walk up and down in the
Student Union there in Columbia and say
do you take vitamins and minerals I was
still fascinated by that and of course
people kind of look at you crazy and say
well yeah I take vitamin E and I'd wait
for them to come up with the other 89
and they didn't they just oh I take
vitamin E well today if you ask people
do you take food supplements they say oh
yeah I take
Tums because that's what you know they
hear all the time well again you need 90
nutrients if you're going to make it but
the newspapers know and the magazines
and TV and radio knows that we're
interested in Health and Longevity and
and supplements so they all talk to us
not because the medical profession has
asked them to do that in their stad the
medical profession doesn't say hey we're
so busy saving people with surgery and
chemotherapy and radiation and
pharmaceuticals would you please educate
the people on nutrition they do it
because it sells newspapers well my
favorite article of all time appeared in
Time Magazine April 6th 1992 and if you
haven't read it I'd urge you to get it
out of a school library or public
library and photocopy of stick one copy
on the door in the bathroom and one on
the refrigerator it's a cover article it
says the real power of vitamins new
research shows they may help fight
cancer heart disease and the ravages of
Aging again there's six positive pages
in here there's only one negative
sentence and was issued by a medical
doctor who was asked by the writer of
the article what do you think what do
you think about vitamins and minerals
for people as food supplements and
here's what the doctor said quote
popping vitamins doesn't do you any good
sniffs Dr Victor Herbert a professor of
Medicine at New York City's Mount Sinai
Medical School we get all the vitamins
we need in our diets and taking
supplements just gives you expensive
urine unquote well to give you a
Missouri translation of that that means
you're just peeing away your dollars if
you take vitamins and minerals you might
as well wad up your dollars and throw
them in the toilet and flush them away
because you're not getting any redeeming
value from it those quacks are just
taking your money for those vitamins and
minerals that's what he was trying to
say got published so it must be true
right after having done those 17,500
autopsies and 454 species of animals
from around the world and then 3,000
humans and liking to be healthy myself
and having children and grandchildren
and not too distant future children I'd
rather pee out 50 cents or dollar a day
worth of excess vitamins and minerals is
pretty cheap insurance if you don't
invest in yourself to the tune of a buck
a day for vitamins and minerals guess
what you're going to invest in the
lifestyle of a MD somewhere because when
you pay the medical doctor your fee for
going to see him not one penny of that
goes to study how to diagnose or treat
or prevent a catastrophic disease and a
little child like who was in here
earlier or how to prevent or diagnose or
treat better breast cancer or prostate
cancer and adults guess what that money
goes for pays the doctor's mortgage
makes his Mercedes payment it pays a
tuition for his kids to go to medical
school at havid you know where havit is
up in Baston pays a tuition for his kids
to go to law school at y between 1776
and the second world war the US
government spent $80 million on
Healthcare and healthc Care research and
studies right now we're at
$1.2 trillion a year for health care and
it's free we all know it's free right
it's not free but we're supposed to
believe it's free and everybody wants
more of it and more free stuff well I'll
tell you what if we used a human type
medical system for the agricultural
industry and the livestock your
hamburger cost $275 a pound on the other
hand if you use the agricultural health
system that we use in animals for humans
your monthly insurance premiums for a
family of five would be $10 a month you
take your choice well I believe since
we've made them wealthy through
Insurance programs and government
subsidies I believe they owe us
something I believe they owe us at least
as much as the industries do according
to for instance recall notices this was
started of course I don't know 25 years
ago when Ralph nater learned that the
Ford Motor Company had made a pinto car
with a rear end gas tank that would blow
up when he got hit from behind at 20 M
hour fry everybody in the car and when
people complained to Ford Motor Company
they said well you're just dumb for
getting in a car accident we're not
going to pay you for that Ralph nater
says no it's a faulty design so he went
to a federal court and the judge agreed
with them and through a court order
forced Ford Motor Company to send
everybody a uh recall note
with a registered letter bring that car
in and they'll fix it for nothing but
they kill 300,000 a year and nobody
protests as long as we get ours free and
that scares me that attitude at any rate
I've got a bunch of these recall notices
you should have gotten over the last
couple years we'll go through them
quickly number one is ulcers how many of
you ever heard that ulcers is caused by
stress okay everybody's heard that if
you don't raise your hand you got
Alzheimer's or your fibon
right well we knew 50 years ago in in
the veterinary industry that ulcers at
least in pigs was caused by a bacteria
called helicobactor pylori and of course
we couldn't get one of these high priced
stomach surgeons from Mayo Clinic in
fact we always used to yell hold the
Mayo when they'd say stuff like that
otherwise your pork chops would be $275
a pound to pay for that kind of surgery
and we learned that with a trace mineral
called bismuth and the Tetra cycling
antibiotic that we could prevent and and
cure those stomach ulcers and pigs
without surgery and so that's what we
did cost five bucks to cure a pig of
stomach ulcers with
bismuth the trace mineral and
tetracycline well the National
Institutes of Health now not the
national Inquirer but the National
Institutes of Health came out in
February 1994 and said ulcers are caused
by a bacteria called helicobactor pylori
not stress and they can be cured they
actually use the Cure word in this news
release medical researchers never do
that they always say it shows promising
results or may be beneficial they use
the Cure word National Institutes of
Health and they say can be cured with a
combination of the trace mineral bismo
and Tetra cycling well for those of you
who don't know what business comes in
you can get it from any grocery store or
drugstore it's pink about $295 for an 8
O bottle and it's called Pepto Bismol so
a teaspoon a day full of Pepto Bismol
and some ormis and calf scour pellets
you can take care of ulcers now you have
your choice whether you're going to
treat your own for five bucks or go get
Whitted on that's your choice then
what's the number two cause of death in
Americans terrible disease called cancer
right now when doctors get information
on cancer you'd think they'd photocopy
that and when they send you that bill
they should send you some photocopies of
this stuff well in September of 1993 the
um National Cancer Institute not the
national Inquirer but the National
Cancer Institute and the um havid
Medical School up in Baston did a study
on cancer patients and they came out and
they said an anti-cancer diet was found
well at any rate they picked China to do
this study because in one Province henan
Province in China they had the highest
rate of cancer in the whole world they
took 29,000 people for 5 years in this
study and what they did was give them
different vitamins and minerals at
Double the recommended daily allowance
for Americans now that's a trivial
amount for instance they use vitamin C
for one group and of course the um RDA
recommended daily allowance for vitamin
C is 60 milligrams double that it's
going to be 120 milligrams you can't go
into a health food store and find a
vitamin C tablet or capsule for less
than 500 milligrams for an adult and of
course lonus Pauling the gentleman with
two Nobel prizes says if you want to
prevent and treat cancer with vitamin C
you got to use 10,000 milligrams a day
well all the doctors who used to argue
with him back 35 years ago are all dead
and today lonus pauling's still 94 and
he works 14 hours a day 7 days a week on
his Ranch in the Big Sir in California
and teaches at the University of
California San Francisco so you have to
make up your choice whether you're going
to listen to the Dead Doctors or lonus
Pauling your choice okay vitamin C
double the RDA nothing happened vitamin
A Double the RDA nothing happened zinc
riboflavin the trace mineral mbum nin
nothing happened in one group they got a
major benefit in this group they got
three nutrients at one time they got
vitamin E they got beta katene and the
trace mineral selenium that those three
were at Double the RDA and if you get a
half a percent benefit in any
nutritional or pharmaceutical experiment
you've made a major Improvement in
Humanity's life and so these articles
get published so I want you to remember
that statistic a half a percent is major
benefit well in this group that received
the vitamin E beta katene and selenium
for 5 years deaths from all causes were
reduced by 9% almost 10 out of every
hundred or one out of every 10 who were
going to die in that 5 Years From Any
cause
survived then cancers all cancers 133%
survived who would have died without
those three
nutrients so 13 out of 100 lived who
would have died and then the type of
cancer that was most prevalent in henan
Province stomach and esophageal cancer
21% lived who would have died 21 out of
100 lived now to me those are
significant numbers and your physician
for the number two cause of death in
America should have sent every one of
you a photocopy of that at least given
you information even if he didn't want
to give you the advice give you the
information let you make up your own
mind well here's one I think is funny on
one hand and on the other side it tells
you the attitude of Physicians this has
to do with arthritis it was in September
24th 199 3 that it was released again it
was from the havit medical school in the
Baston VA Hospital how many of you in
here have ever been to a VA Hospital
anybody in this room okay good well you
know the people who've been to a VA
Hospital you have two opportunities to
give your life for your country once on
the field of battle and the others in
the VA Hospital right well at any rate
the title of the release was chicken
protein hals the swelling and pain of
arthritis in a patient trial and what
they did they took people who failed to
respond in any way to medical treatment
for arthritis these people got gold
shots mesot trexate they got aspirin
prednizone cortisone everything else you
can think of physical therapy and the
only thing left for them was joint
replacement surgery okay now before
Harvard Medical School the VA hospital
was going to give it to them they said
look we're looking for some people who
are willing to suffer for 90 more days
just three months because we want to try
something a short-term experiment and
they got 29 volunteers and what they did
for those 29 volunteers who failed to
respond in any way to medical treatment
for arthritis was they gave them a
heaping teaspoon full of ground up dried
chicken cartilage in their orange juice
every morning just a heaping teaspoon of
ground up chicken cartilage and in 10
days according to Harvard Medical School
all the pain and inflammation was gone
these are people who didn't respond in
any way to medical
treatment in 30 days they could open up
a new pickle jar that never been opened
and 90 days 3 months they had maximum
return of function here's the funny part
the funny part comes by statement of the
guy who was the director of that study
from Harvard Medical School and here's
what he said quote listen to the words
are very important quote after three
months it was clear that the drug was
beneficial unquote because it worked
chicken cartilage had become a
drug you can see he's thinking about
patent numbers and his eyes are rolling
around with 300 bucks a capsule 20
patients and you can just see him
calculating
right that means if you go to Kentucky
Fried Chicken and you buy a a chicken
throw away the skin and the meat and eat
the ends off the bones you're practicing
medicine without a
license and if you go to a Kentucky
Fried Chicken in the middle of the night
in the dark of the night and you go to
their dumpster and you root through
there and you collect two five gallon
feed buckets full of chicken bones and
you take them home with a hammer and you
pound off the ends of those bones and
dry your own cartilage in the microwave
you know you're manufacturing a
pharmaceutical and the FDA is going to
put you in jail next time I come by here
in 3 months you're going to run up on
this stage and hug me and kiss me if you
arthritis how many you ever heard of
Alzheimer's disease everybody's heard
about it today 50 years ago when I was a
little kid there's no such thing as
Alzheimer's disease it's a new disease
one of those things that just sort of
happened now it's a major disease one
out of every two people who reach age 70
get Alzheimer's disease pretty scary we
learned 50 years ago in the animal
industry how to prevent and cure in the
early stages Alzheimer's disease and
livestock you imagine how much a farmer
would lose if the pigs were all laying
there scratching their head saying why
am am I
here where is the feed box because if
they're not gaining a couple of pounds a
day you're losing money right so we
learned in the agricultural industry how
to prevent and in the early stages cure
Alzheimer's disease and we do it with
high doses of vitamin E and low intakes
of vegetable oil you say wall like
that's crazy high doses of vitamin E
well you should have got a recall notice
from your doctor in July of 1992 because
the University of California I mean
we're talking about sophisticated
research school here University of
California San Diego came out and said
vitamin E eases memory loss in
Alzheimer's victims now they're only 50
years behind on that from veterinary
medicine so it might be safer going to a
veterinarian then how many of you in
this room ever had a kidney stone
anybody in here ever get that kidney
stone okay I see a few in here what's
the first thing a doctor told you to
give up nutritionally when you got your
kidney stone give up calcium no Dairy no
Dairy none of those vitamin mineral
things with calcium in them CU they have
the stupid naive ignorant belief that's
pretty intense they have the stupid
ignorant naive belief that the calcium
in your kidney stone comes from the
calcium you eat when in fact it comes
from your own bones when you have a
raging Calcium deficiency a raging
osteoporosis then you get kidney stones
we learned years ago in writing in the
agricultural industry if you wanted to
prevent kidney stones and livestock you
better give them more calcium you better
give them more magnesium and more Boron
now the reason is of course bulls and
rams male cattle and sheep have special
Anatomy when they get a kidney stone
they die they call water belly they die
when you and I get a kidney stone we
just wish we were dead but no farmer is
dumb enough to pay for the feed for an
animal and have it die before you can
either eat it or send it to Market so we
learned how to prevent those things well
you should have got a recall notice from
your doctor especially you people who've
had kidney stones your urologist should
have sent a notice to you this was uh
March of 1993 it says uh calcium limits
kidney stone risk and this is from the
havit Medical School up in Baston by the
way in a study that turns conventional
medical wisdom on its head researchers
have found that people whose diets are
rich in calcium run a reduce risk of
developing kidney stones and a study of
more than 45,000 people that who were
ranked into five categories the group
that had the most calcium had no kidney
stones now about five years ago when I
started out on this Crusade and started
lecturing to people all across America
and I'm in one time zone and the next
and all over I knew I was going to get
crazy out there uh doing this last year
I was on the road 300 days out of the
Year 300 out of 365 days and so I
decided I needed to have a hobby that I
could take with me every time I get a
little wacko I could go in my room and
do this Hobby and I'd be okay you know
be kind of like having a little piece of
home with me wherever I went and I
wanted to have a hobby that would uh uh
help other people I didn't want to
collect baseball cards because I like
football and I didn't want to do just
crossword puzzles because good mental
exercise but wouldn't help anybody else
and um I couldn't take my compost pile I
like to garden and the hotels don't like
that you know so I decided I was going
to collect obituaries of doctors and
lawyers now as crazy as that sounds
remember I told you the doctors live to
an average age of 58 and we live to 75.5
and here's a group of people
professionals who pontificate you and
tell you well this is what you need to
do you need to give up salt and uh no
caffeine and you need to not eat butter
and eat margarine and do all these crazy
things and they die at age 58 on the
average and anyway I got a few of them
here some of my favorites this is Dr
Stuart Cartwright age 38 he dropped dead
in his home he was a family practitioner
of a ruptured aneurysm that's a
ballooning of an artery that's a
weakened artery because of the uh
fragmenting or the brittle condition of
the elastic fibers and arteries just
like when you hit a Chuck hole with your
car tire and you break the cords in
there and you get a balloon he dropped
dead like he was poleaxed okay right in
his home from aupt aneurysm now we
learned in 19 oh I think it was uh
57 aneurysms are caused by a copper
deficiency we had a pilot project
turkeys and we made complete food
pellets where you put all the 90
nutrients in there and in the first 13
weeks fully half of those turkeys died
farmers were out there every morning
picking them up by the bushel basket
they took them to the state diagnostic
labs and their autopsy and they found
out that they all had died from a
ruptured a Arctic aneurysm so they
doubled the amount of copper in there
and the next year they didn't lose a
single turkey from a ruptured AR Artic
aneurysm and they ran that experiment in
mice and rats and rabbits and dogs and
cats and uh Cales and sheep and pigs and
whatnot and guess what they found out
that there's a whole series of diseases
that are caused by a copper deficiency
gray hair is the first sign when you
start getting gray hair regardless of
your age you got a copper deficiency you
get skin wrinkles because the elastic
fibers in your skin are going those
little crows feet around your eyes and
facial and body skin wrinkles you look
like you're a little prune drying up
okay then of course there's the um
varicose
veins that's caused by an elastic fiber
breakdown then of course parts of your
body begin to Sag under your arms your
breast your bellies your legs all this
stuff starts sagging and you can go to a
cosmetic surgeon or plastic surgeon if
you want but it's a lot cheaper and a
lot more effective and a lot safer if
you just take some copper Dr cartwrite
may have had a medical degree but he
didn't have expensive urine so he died
to something that even a turkey wouldn't
die from
then here's one this fellow he was a
doctor's doctor Dr Martin Carter he
almost made it he died at age 57 he got
his medical degree from havid medical
school and his PhD in medicine from Yale
he was autopsied by the best because he
was a doctor's Doctor Who said quote the
cause of death was a ruptured atic
aneurism said Dr Jules HS the
Rockefeller University Hospital unquote
what did he die from copper deficiency
see he didn't have expensive urine
either then here's an attorney she was
so famous she was from Detroit age 44
Ellen Joyce alter uh she was in the New
York Times obituary she made the big
time and uh of course she probably had
steel buns because she belonged to one
of those private health clubs all these
gals want steel buns you know doing
their little
exercises but she didn't have expensive
urine because she died of a ruptured
cerebral
aneurysm when they don't do an autopsy
the symptoms could be called a stroke or
uh subdural Hemorrhage but very
frequently they're caused by a ruptured
aneurysm which is a copper deficiency
she didn't have expensive urine how many
of you here have ever heard of a guy by
the name of Stuart Burger Stuart Burger
he he wrote five bestselling books on
health and diets and nutrition he got
his medical degree from TS medical
school which is a very fine medical
school in Boston not too far away from
uh Harvard Medical School and the books
he wrote included the Southampton diet
for weight loss he wrote Forever Young
20 years younger and 20 weeks and how to
be your own nutritionist and he died at
age 40 how'd you like to follow his
dietary practices he died at age 40 of
cardiomyopathy which is a selenium
deficiency the same cause as white
muscle disease or or stiff lamb disease
and any farmer can go to a feed store
and get selenium pellets or selenium
injections things like celotto and boy
and so forth and Dr Stuart bur a guy who
wrote five best-selling books on
nutrition died of a nutritional
deficiency he didn't have expensive of
urine you can prevent totally prevent
cardiomyopathy for 10 cents a day and if
we don't do it we're malignant dumb I
like to call it you're malignant dumb if
you don't take in 10 cents a day worth
of selenium it's a waste of your life
that's one of those landmines you can
avoid the medical treatment of choice
for cardiomyopathy is a heart transplant
cost
$750,000 I want you to think about that
they get the heart free from a donor
they get the blood free for the surgery
from the relatives they use $2.50 worth
of suture material and they charged
$750,000 for that procedure now 6 months
ago in La when they had the earthquake
they were putting people in jail for 60
and 90 days for price gouging for
selling these terrified people a gallon
of water for
$4 they put him in jail for price
gouging for selling him a gallon of
water for four bucks now to me that's
entrepreneurialism you know that's being
in business for yourself if you had a a
way to distill water and make water and
you had a car and you could get in there
and sell those people a gallon of water
for four bucks hey more power to you
because if you go to a 7-Eleven and buy
a quart of Evan water it's
$129 so four of those courts is five
bucks kind of interesting isn't it they
said it was price gouging because those
people were terrified well talk about a
person who needs a new heart they're
terrified
$750,000 we should put those doctors in
jail but we bow to them because oh
that's high-tech medicine out of 270
million people in America you save about
50 a year is that costeffective I don't
think so Dr Stuart burer didn't have
expensive urine and here's the last one
and many of you may know this woman uh
her name is Dr Gail Clark she was age 47
she was the chief cardiologist of the
West St Louis County group of hospitals
uh she was the chief cardiologist for
the um St Mary's Health Center in
Richmond Heights in St Louis County she
was aged 47 guess what she died from
heart attack a cardiopathy heart attack
you can just see her walking down the
hall she's got the stethoscope around
her neck you know this is their little
status symbol got my stethoscope around
my neck back when I was in school they
folded it up very bravely and put it in
their pocket boom she falls down she has
a heart attack right in the hall and of
course the nurses scoop her up and put
her on a gurnie and they call the
technicians and another doctor code
three code three code blue whatever it
is and they whip her into the room and
you can hear him let's say you're a
cardiac patient you're laying there
you're all hooked up to the monitors and
the IVs and and you hear him say okay te
closeth off okay stand back didn't work
turn it up stand back and then you hear
that terrible sound when you know that
the treatment didn't
work the flat line when you know the
heart is gone and everybody walks out of
the room dejected and you say nurse
nurse what happened next door and she
says well you're cardiologist you know
the chief cardiologist of this Hospital
age 47 Dr Gail Clark just died of a
cardiomyopathy heart attack we can see
all the patients they're holding their
gowns and they're running out of that
hospital leaving their watches and their
shoes and their checkbooks and
everything their plastic credit cards
because they don't want to get what Dr
Gail Clark got to me the reader digest
is a magazine that never says anything
negative or bad about anybody or any
group it's the sweetest little magazine
that ever was the September 1993 issue
features an article it says can you
trust your doctor it lists 12 ways the
doctors scam your money and I'll let you
read 11 of them yourself I'll give you
the worst one in addition to their
income from Office fees and surgical
fees and lab fees and hospitalization
doctors get a kick Ki back from the labs
and the the X-ray labs and Clinics and
hospitals they get a kickback of
$421 every time they send you in for a
CAT scan or an
MRI and doctors tell you oh we do that
because we're practicing defensive
medicine because if I miss something you
know one in 10 billion you're going to
sue me so I do this just to protect
myself well if it was just to protect
themselves and you knew them and they
knew you 90% of the people say I'll just
skip it DOC if you don't really think
it's necessary let's save the money but
they got something more than defensive
medicine to worry about they get 421
bucks in a kickback for every time they
send you in for an MRI or a CAT scan
well when I practice for 12 years up in
Portland somebody come to me with a
terrible headache never had one i' just
walk up to them and tap them on the
sinuses and if they' collapsed to their
knees I know they had a sinus headache
oh doc why'd you do that well I just
wanted that's a cheap lab test you
know then if they had thank you if they
had blood dripping out of their nose it'
take a $35 x-ray to see if they had a
cancer in there 35 bucks in a free lab
test as opposed to 421 bucks if I wanted
to make that 421 bucks I'd have been a
good Thief what I'd have done I'd have
build a choot right into that cat scan
machine cuz I knew how to build shoots
living on a farm and I'd have gone out
in the street and I'd have got every
homeless person I'd line them up in them
shoots and I'd put soup in a Big Mac at
the end of that tube you know and I'd
say I'm going to give buy you a $150
dinner I'm a good guy I'm going to buy
you $150 dinner you just got to go
through the shoot go through that tube
and you get your sandwich and your soup
man they'd be flowing through there
maybe a hundred a day and I could start
adding some things up it'd be a lot of
fun any R the average doctor gets
$228,600
[Applause]
pays for it we don't mind if they steal
it's blind it's free remember I told you
I was going to tell you about
Pica Pica is a funny disease Pica I'm
not talking about the type style that
you see in typewriters and computers but
Pica is a disease that farmers know
about in hores is called cribbing when
they chew on the feed bunk the wooden
feed bunk you know you better give them
some minerals otherwise they're going to
eat that feed bunk and cattle dairy
cattle especially where they're losing
lots of minerals through their milk all
the time intensive milking you'll see
them picking up big rocks in the creek
and chewing on them or they'll chew on
Bob wire or maybe you'll see them
walking down through a path with a deer
bone in their mouth or something or a
shingle that's called Pica and a good
farmer a husband drean knows you better
give them some minerals otherwise
they're going to eat the barn or
something in human beings we see this at
funny times pregnant women are notorious
for Pica uh in the middle of the night
they'll elbow their husband and say Hey
you better get up I want some uh pickles
and ice cream they're craving minerals
because that fetus is pulling minerals
out of their body they need some more
minerals and so it's is recognized as a
craving for things like sweets and salt
we see this in pregnant women I used to
have people come to my practice and they
say Doc do I need to go see a shrink I
said why is that well I wake up in the
middle of the night and I go outside
with a spoon and I eat dirt and no
that's okay just make sure it's clean
dirt then they say my my kid sits there
with a kitty litter box between his legs
and he has a spoon and he's eating that
stuff out of the kitty litter box and
then in housing projects little kids
will eat lead paint off the walls and
they get lead poison get learning
disabilities and Bone problems and
anemia and we're good so we spend $5
million to scrape the lead paint off of
there and repaint it with latex paint
and all you have to do is give those
kids 10 cents a day worth of minerals it
be better for them and save us 5 million
bucks it's your tax money and if we
allow him to throw them away those
dollars is kind of interesting if you
have a selenium deficiency and you don't
want to wait until you get
cardiomyopathy and drop dead from a
heart attack to recognize it if you look
on your hand and look in the mirror in
your face if you have liver spots or age
spots and I see quite a few from
here you have an early selenium
deficiency that's called free radical
damage and fortunately for you if you
recognize that and you start taking in
some selenium in four to six months
those will go away you'll reverse that
in four to six months and when they go
away on the outside they're going away
on the inside your brain and your heart
and your liver and your kidneys then if
you have low blood sugar how many in
this room have low blood sugar anybody
in here have low blood sugar okay about
10% how many ever seen a hyperactive kid
who gets on sugar okay about everybody
in the room people who have sugar
problems are like alcoholics there's
good ones and bad ones you know the good
alcoholics are one when they get two
drinks they just go off in a corner and
go to sleep right same way with somebody
with low blood sugar they eat a big meal
or they eat a piece of pie 3 hours later
they clunk out and go to sleep then
there's bad alcoholics they're the one
that gets two drinks in them and they
get violent and raged and they want to
fight everybody punch holes in the wall
you know big Brave fellows and they kick
their wife and kick the dog and take the
chainsaw and cut their neighbors tree
down and all these wild things and drive
Reckless down the roads and kill people
those are the bad drunks well people who
have blood sugar problems there's bad
blood sugar people too they get a little
crazy okay I don't know how many of you
remember the twinkie
defense right remember somebody murdered
two people and he claimed he ate a
Twinkie three hours before he murdered
him so they let him off because he got
temporarily insane every time he ate
sugar now don't any of you try that well
chromium and vadium deficiency will
result in the sugar problems low blood
sugar and if you let it go on for any
length of time you develop diabetes
chromium and vadium then a tin
deficiency the early symptoms of a tin
deficiency or male pattern baldness I
see a lot of tin deficiency in this room
yes and if you let it go on for any
length of time you get deafness then
there's a boron deficiency and you gal
should know about boron because it helps
you keep the calcium you take in in your
bones so you don't get
osteoporosis Boron all it helps you make
estrogen it helps you fellas make
testosterone if you don't take in enough
Boron you ladies are going to suffer
miserably going through menopause okay
you're going to have all those terrible
symptoms you fellas don't get enough
Boron can't make testosterone you won't
know whether to lead or follow on the
Dance
Floor you're going to be
confused she's saying he's got a boron
deficiency
the first symptoms of a zinc deficiency
is you lose your sense of smell and your
taste you say oh you know food just
doesn't taste good anymore and you don't
have a cold or anything like that and
you say your wife says well aren't you
excited about dinner I spent the whole
day in the kitchen cooking dinner he
said well I didn't smell anything when I
walk in you know he's got a zinc
deficiency well in laboratory animals
there's some seven rare Earths these
rare Earths are trace minerals you need
in lesser amounts than you need trace
minerals and they actually double the
lifespan of laboratory animals they've
not been proven in humans yet but I'm
not going to wait 500 years for doctors
to approve it they're still arguing over
vitamin C and calcium right so I'm just
going to do it didn't kill any
laboratory animals just doubles her life
and it's not a drug these rare Earths
are called lanthanum prium neodium
samarium europium yium and thulium there
must be a reason why they're named after
Old Testament cities well remember I
told you we needed 90 nutrients we need
60 minerals we need 16 vitamins 12
essential amino acids and three
essential fatty acids and of course
we're lucky in that plants as a group
can make most vitamins amino acids and
fatty acids plants can do that because
they just take carbon out of the air and
make carbon chains to make vitamins
amino acids and fatty acids but you have
to eat 15 to 25 different plants a day
in the right combinations to make this
happen theoretically it's possible but
most Americans don't do it the average
American thinks if they eat some potato
buds out of a Betty Crocker box or
eating a vegetable okay so you got to be
careful what you're considering a
vegetable then of course people want to
do right by their doctor and they eat
lowfat turkey breast and they put a half
a jar of mayonnaise on there and they
put it between two slices of Wonder
styrofoam bread remember that stuff you
can insulate your house with and put in
your shoes when you get a hole in shoe I
remember when I was a kid it was a lot
of fun because we have Wonderbread we
didn't have TVs back then on the farm we
didn't even have dryers that went round
and around so the only thing you could
do in the winter time was sit in the
kitchen and wanded a loaf of Wonderbread
and had the blue and red and green
yellow balloons on there and if you read
the label as many times as I do you know
it said things like helps build bodies
at 12 ways and about 15 years later the
FDA made them change it to help build
your body eight ways now if you go to
the store and look at Wonderbread
rappers it just says Wonderbread so it
kind of gives you a
clue so even though this is
theoretically possible it's not likely
to happen that you're going to get your
vitamins amino acids and fatty acids in
proper proportions from your diet and so
if your life is as valuable to you as
mine is to me and my children's and my
grandchildren's is to me I would make
sure that I take in all my vitamins and
amino acids and fatty acids because I
guarantee you won't make it to 120 if
you don't you're just not going to do it
now minerals are another story we have a
tragic story when it comes to minerals
because plants cannot make minerals in
any way shape or form and if they're not
in the soil anymore they're not in our
plants our farm soils and our rain soils
are depleted of minerals and the crops
the grains the fruits and the vegetables
and the nuts that are grown on these
depleted farm and Rain soils are
minerally deficient the people who eat
them get mineral deficiency diseases and
the only way to prevent and cure them is
with mineral supplements do you think
it's gotten any better no it has not
gotten any better it's only gotten worse
and the reason is if you guys do what we
did and people continue to do is we put
NPK on our land nitrogen phosphorus
potassium and you see it as these three
numbers in many combinations of ratios
and these represent percentages of these
three nutrients nitrogen phosphorus
pottassium and those of you who don't
have any experience on farms the reason
why we do this is farmers get paid for
tons and bushels there's no subsidy that
encourages people to put 60 minerals
back in the soil you get paid for tons
and bushels and for 40 bucks an acre you
can get the maximum yield in tons and
bushels it only takes 5 to 10 years to
deplete the land of minerals cuz every
time you harvest a crop those plants
pull minerals out of the soil many
pounds per acre every time you haul a
crop out so soon those minerals are gone
and if you only put back in three and
you take out 60 it's like a checking
account if you only put three bucks in
your checking account every month and
write checks for 60 what's going to
happen to your checks boing boing boing
they bounce exactly well I can tell you
that our health is bouncing right now to
the tune of $1.2 trillion a year it's
our responsibility each and every one of
us to be responsible for our health and
consciously take in these minerals I
have a lot of people ask me what did
these people do thousands of years ago
they didn't even have commercial
fertilizers what did they do these
societies that had long lived people and
whatnot I want you to think about the
Egyptians the Chinese people from India
that lived around these Great Rivers the
Nile River the Ganges River the yalo
river in China and what used to happen
was every year our so would flood just
like it did here in Northern Missouri
last year and every time it flooded
guess what would happen it would bring
silt or rock dust from from Mountains
from 500 or thousand miles away and
those people would pray to every God
they had the water God the sky God the
wind God The Rock God to flood we pray
don't flood they used to pray to flood
because they had their floods during the
winter time and would put silt and
minerals back in the soil and their
grain was very valuable King Phillip
who's the father of uh Alexander the
Great married the 12-year-old child
queen of Egypt Cleopatra she didn't look
like Elizabeth Taylor all made up in
beautiful costumes she was a little
flatchested teeny bopper not very sexy
but Philip married her because she
controlled the best wheat in the world
and if he wanted his Macedonian army to
conquer the world through his son
Alexander the Great he needed the best
wheat in the world so he could March 20
hours a day fight for 6 hours and win if
they used the wheat from the depleted
soils and grease they couldn't go 20
minutes without saying mommy pick me up
can you imagine these big Greek soldiers
Oh my legs hurt pick me up and so they
knew the best place to get wheat was
from Egypt it was those floods that gave
them those minerals and all those
cultures that came up with all the great
art and all the great technology came
from those places because they had more
intelligence because they had more
nutrition more minerals I heard somebody
say very good well you're getting the
picture well what I'm going to do here
is I'm just going to pick out a couple
of minerals just a couple of them so you
get the idea it applies to all of them
let's just pick out a common one like
calcium everybody knows about calcium
Calcium deficiency will result in
something like a 147 different diseases
they're just different names they're
named after people like Bells paly you
know everybody knows about that one side
of your face sags it's not a true stroke
it just affects your facial muscles it's
caused by Calcium deficiency we'll talk
about in a little bit but everybody
knows about this one osteoporosis it's
the number 10 killer of adults in United
States it's very expensive it cost you
$35,000 each for each hip to replace
it's okay it's free insurance will pay
for it cost you $70,000 for both hips as
expensive as it is and the number 10
killer remember Mrs SK from Radford
Virginia aged 115 years of age she died
of complications of a fall we don't have
osteoporosis and animals and it's
because of farmers we don't have
osteoporosis and animals goes like this
you have a a pasture with a 100 cows in
it and this year you didn't have any
calves you can't repay your operating
loan you're in trouble right cuz you
paid for the feed and the vet bill and
mowed the pasture and fertiliz and
maintained the fence and fed the cows
and all this that and the other you
don't have any cash you can't pay back
the operating loan and make any money so
you call the vet out and you say do I
get rid of these cows what happened here
and he examines the cows he says nothing
wrong with them says let me look at the
bull he says aha here's your problem
that bull has osteoporosis of both hips
can't breed the cows didn't have any
calvs he says I'll tell you what though
he says you give me $70,000 he says I'll
put two new hips in that bull next year
you'll have some calvs well the first
thing that farmer says is stand back doc
boom
he blows that bull away with a deer
rifle and while the kids are grinding
the bull up with a grinder and cutting
roast and steaks off that bull the
farmer is chewing on a straw and saying
now Doc pushes Stetson up a little bit
and he says you know I wasn't going to
pay you $70,000 for that old bull he
says I get a new bull every year for 70
years for that he says but every once in
a while I get a bull that throws good
calves I'd like to keep them is there
any way I can prevent that osteoporosis
thing for happening to a good bull he
says well yeah he says if you'll give a
bull calf 10 cents worth of calcium
every day after he's weaned he'll never
get osteoporosis F wait a minute doc you
mean if I give that bull 10 cents a day
worth of calcium from the time he's
weaned I can prevent a
$70,000 disaster oh yeah it's that
simple he says you mean all I have to do
is give up a half a cup of coffee a day
to do that he says yeah that's it he
says I choose that one he said I'll give
up the half a cup of coffee and that's
what we have to think like then there's
receding gums dentist and periodontist
will tell you that if you want to
prevent and cure receding gums you
better floss and brush after every meal
if you believe that works I have some
oceanfront property in Montana to sell
you if you all know your geography you
know that doesn't work now as a
veterinarian I've seen hundreds of
thousands of animals of all kinds mice
rats rabbits dogs cats sheep pigs horses
lions and tigers and bears and they
don't get receding gums and they don't
floss now they do get funky breath but
they don't get receding gums well if you
want to smell something you just let a
camel breathe on you boy
well the reason we don't have receding
gums in livestock is because we've dealt
with the osteoporosis problem receding
gums is not a deficiency of flossing
it's in fact osteoporosis of the jaw
bones and of the facial Bon so if you
have gingivitis or receding gums you
have advanced osteoporosis those bones
around your teeth are melting away
little bit by little bit every day and
if you take your teeth out at night and
put them in a glass next to your bed and
that fizzy stuff you have major advanced
osteoporosis because all your bone B has
melted away then there's arthritis we
talked about that a little bit earlier
remember the chicken cartilage 85% of
all arthritis is caused by osteoporosis
of the joint ends of the bones you're
talking about degenerative arthritis
osteoarthritis sciatica lumbago
rheumatism all those sorts of things um
they're caused by osteoporosis of the
joint ends of the bones I want you to
think about something for a minute if
you don't take a pain reliever or or an
anti-inflammatory for that arthritis
let's say you get arthritis of the hips
you're going to kind of favor that a
little bit aren't you you're going to
get a cane or a walker or crutches
you're going to favor it and so you
don't put any weight on it I want you to
think about that for just a second
because then I want you to think about
driving your tractor in a field or
you're driving a Mercedes down the
highway either one doesn't matter
whichever you love more let's say you
didn't put the nut on that oil pan real
tight and all the oil drained out and
that light on the dashboard comes on
says I'm getting hot you better give me
some oil and that light irritates you so
you stop you open up the hood you get
get your clippers out you know your
fence Clippers and you clip the wire to
that light and you close the hood and
you just keep driving would you do that
to your tractor or your Mercedes no you
wouldn't but we take those pain
relievers for arthritis and we go out
there and square dance and do the Texas
toep and do our five mile walks and our
aerobics that pill Works real good doc
cuz it killed my pain and you're just
wearing that thing off faster and faster
then your doctor is really going to get
rich because you need joint replacement
surgery then there's hypertension this
is one of my favorites I'll put star
over here hypertension is high blood
pressure what's the first nutritional
thing that a doctor will tell you to
give up nutritionally when you get high
blood pressure give up salt everybody
knows that one that's been ingrained in
our head well they must think we're
dumber than cows because what's the
first thing you put out for your
livestock and about that big a salt
block no farmer is going to be
economically viable if you don't put a
salt block out for your livestock
they're going to die kind your
Veterinary bills are going to go crazy
but we're supposed to believe that we
don't need salt you can get everything
you need out of your lettuce and your
whole wheat bread and stuff like that
well don't believe that one either if
you believe that I got some more
oceanfront property in Montana for you
they took $30 million of your tax money
and two years ago after a 20e study they
came out and said that they took 5,000
people with high blood pressure they
took them off their medication and put
them on a reduced salt diet a restricted
salt diet and they all died no big
surprise but somebody got a PhD degree
and everybody was happy right but when
they looked at this results they said
that oh only 99.7 % of the people didn't
get any results from that before they
died 0.3% did get some result dropped
their blood pressure one point before
they died by restricting their salt so
the referees who judged that article
said oh doesn't matter you might as well
let high blood pressure patients eat
salted peanuts and deal pickles and salt
their food to taste because it doesn't
matter in fact worrying about the salt
is more stress than taking the salt then
they had a control group with 5,000
people with high blood pressure and they
doubled their RDA of calcium and they
stopped the experiment 6 weeks because
85% of them were cured of their high
blood pressure just by doubling their
calcium intake now they didn't cold
turkey stop their high blood pressure
medication but what they did was they
went to the doctor and says you don't
need this medication anymore what are
you doing well I'm on this experiment
where I double my calcium intake anybody
get a recall notice from your doctor
saying it's okay to Salt your food to
taste and please do double your calcium
intake anybody get that not a single one
that's very interesting then of course
there's insomnia that's where you roll
around all night you wake up in the
morning you're more tired when you went
to bed that's insomnia of course doctors
have two treatments for that they have
hion which is a sleeping pill and they
have barbituates they kill about 10,000
people a year with overdoses of those
things but that's okay it's a
prescription and they're watching out
for us and remember George Bush when he
went to Japan they gave him some helon
so he could sleep on the way to Japan
because of the time difference and when
he woke up one of the side effects of
hethon is nausey and
vomiting I don't know how you say it in
Japanese but it was very dramatic on
world TV right not very
presidential and so I'm sure that's why
he lost the election because he puked
over that Japanese
Ambassador and then of course there's
kidney stones and then there's bone
spurs heel spurs and calcium deposits
again Physicians will tell you the first
thing to give up nutritionally is
calcium and dairy because they have this
foolish belief the stupid belief the
ignorant belief that the calcium in
kidney stones bone spurs heel spurs and
calcium deposits come from your diet
when instead it only comes from your
bones when you have a raging
osteoporosis and when you get these
things you need more calcium not less
then there's cramps and Twitches you
wake up in the middle of the night and
your foot is all cramped up around your
neck and you say Lord take me from the
knee down I'm not going to make it till
morning we've all experienced that
that's very common then there's PMS
premenstrual syndrome you know the
emotional and physical stuff the medical
treatment of choice for PMS is what we
call a hysterical ectomy it's been
shorten to hysterectomy that's a 100y
old treatment the doctors do about
285,000 unnecessary hysterical ectomies
a year but it makes Mercedes payments so
they do them even the AMA said they're
unnecessary but they don't take their
licenses away and people keep going to
them you imagine a poor woman in her 30s
she says doc you got to do something
every time I go out to hang out the
clothes my neighbors kids run down the
basement screaming which my own kids
think I'm crazy my husband's leaving me
I'm going to lose my job you got to do
something well the University of
California San Diego came out three
years ago now and said if you just
double the RDA of calcium intake you get
rid of 85% of the emotional and physical
symptoms of PMs and when that came out
there were huge lines around the health
food stores around the blocks and people
had sleeping bags cuz they closed before
they all got their calcium and every
person in line was a
man they were there for their daughters
and their girlfriends and their wives
and things like that okay and lastly is
low back pain 85% of Americans get low
back pain where you work on a computer
or you unload hay or you drive big
trucks doesn't matter low back is a big
problem low back is just osteoporosis or
the vertebrae whether you have a disc
problem or whatnot because if your disc
doesn't have anything to hold on to your
vertebrae melted away what's going to
happen to the disc especially if you
have a copper deficiency because they're
made out of elastic fibers they go like
a water balloon with a lot of pressure
on them I just want you to look at this
quickly before we do the last mineral
low back you go to an orthopedic surgeon
or rheumatologist you might get a muscle
relaxant you might get valium and a
muscle relaxant you get a laminectomy
you get your vertebrae fuse you might
get a disc operation they don't tell you
75% of the time you'll never be the same
again right PMS you go to your
OBGYN you can um go to an internist you
can go to a family counselor a shrink or
divorce attorney cramps and and Twitches
you go to a neurologist you go to a
sports medicine doctor an internist bone
spurs heel spurs calcium deposits you go
to a rheumatologist an orthopedic
surgeon or a podiatrist kidney stones
you go to a urologist or an internist or
a surgeon insomnia you go to a shrink or
a um Sleep Clinic or an internist
hypertension you go to a Cardiologist an
internist or a surgeon arthritis a
rheumatologist a orthopedic surgeon or
an internist receding gums you go to a
dentist or a periodontist osteoporosis
you go to all those Health Specialists
including a tum salesman for nothing
more than a Calcium deficiency it cost
you 10 cents a day to deal with now on
the average because Americans have
insurance and we have Medicare and
Medicaid we spend on the average
$25,000 to
$250,000 and we undergo 5 to 10 surgical
procedures a year for a Calcium
deficiency and we beg the doctors to do
it we beg the doctors to do it well it's
our choice the last one I'll share with
you
is diabetes everybody's touched by
diabetes it's the number three cause of
death in adults in the United States
number three cause of death and it has
terrible complications and side effects
diabetes the side effects include
blindness of many kinds then there's a
kidney failure with dialysis and kidney
transplant there's cardiovascular
disease of all kinds and of course that
contributes the number one cause of
death then there is amputations
everybody ought to have one of those CU
they're totally paid for in their health
thing they assume that you're not just
going to get one because you want to get
everything on your health benefits and
then you shorten your life because if
you have diabetes on the average you
have a shorter lifespan than someone who
doesn't have diabetes now we learned in
1957 in the animal industry that we
could prevent and cure diabetes with two
trace minerals that's a pretty profound
statement that we could prevent and cure
diabetes with two trace minerals in 1957
and animals it was published in
Federation proceedings which is the
official Journal of the American Science
the National Institutes of Health the
official monthly Journal was August
1957 well the two trace minerals that
you can get to prevent and cure this are
chromium and vadium vadium alone
according to the University of Vancouver
British Columbia Medical School vadium
alone will replace insulin in adult
onset diabetics which represent 85% of
all diabetics of course they can't quit
their insulin cold turkey they got to
gradually wean off of it takes four to 6
months for most people to slowly wean
off of insulin if they're taking in
adequate amounts of chromium and vadium
now to me this is Criminal because if
you write to a Hills packing company
that makes Science Diet dog food right
over here in TOA Kansas they manufacture
Science Diet dog food and other Science
Diet product high-tech foods for Animals
if you write them and say how many
minerals exactly is in Science Diet for
dog food they'll write you back and say
there's 40 minerals you write
checkerboard Square in St Louis Ral
impian say just how many minerals are in
your rat pellets for laboratory rats and
they'll say there's 28 minerals I'll
give anybody in this room a crisp new
$100 bill if you can find me a human
infant formula in a grocery store that
has more than 11 so our dogs get 4y
minerals remember that's what Mike
Murphy was saying his dog never seems to
get sick cuz he's getting this canned
dog food with all these vitamins and
minerals in there so our dogs get 40
minerals our rats get 28 minerals and
our human infants get 11 is that fair no
that's called
fraud doesn't matter if you're talking
about SMA Similac Isomil Pro soy B fact
that's why they call Similac Similac cuz
it lacks
everything okay if I've convinced you
that you have to consciously take in all
the minerals yourself that you can't
depend on your food and certainly you
can't depend on anything that's boxed or
packaged or bottled there's three types
of minerals that you have to be
concerned about one is metallic minerals
and metallic minerals are essentially
ground up rocks metallic minerals are
things like oyster shell egg shell
Dolomite Limestone uh calcium carbonate
Clays of various kinds Mount marinite
clay seabed minerals
Tums they're only 8 to 12% absorbable
When You Reach age 35 to 40 it drops
down to 3 to 5% and I have to tell you a
story here I ran into a guy at a meeting
like this up at Grand Rapid Michigan and
this fell owns a portapotty business you
know that's that green or blue colored
ouse man if we' only had one of those
back when I was a kid we had these ones
with splinters you know in the wood he
said I see something that that describes
that in my portapotty business I said
what's that he says well when we take
those things back to the shop to clean
them out with the pressure hose he says
we put a quarter-inch grid underneath
them because kids throw rocks and sticks
and toys in there and if we don't put a
grid there it blocks up the sewer system
it cost us thousands of dollars to fix
it every time we clean one of those out
we find hundreds of vitamin tablets I
said well how do you know vitamin
tablets he says well it's really easy he
says right on the coating it says terram
M One A Day
Centrum he says come here he takes me
out in the back of his shop and there's
this literal mountain of all these
vitamin pills he got out of his porta
potties if you read the labels on those
multiples they say your iron comes in
the form of iron oxide what is iron
oxide rust you might as well just go out
to an old railroad track and take your
butter knife and scrape some of that
rust off and lick it and you're going to
get your iron sub that's what they're
giving you I'll show you how bad it is
if you take something like calcium
lactate which is a common metallic
mineral let's say it's a calcium tab
calcium lactate 1,000 milligrams if you
take two of those you're not getting
2,000 milligrams of calcium in fact I
have people all the time say well I took
lots of calcium doc I hear you on the
radio talking about calcium and
arthritis and I took 2,000 milligrams of
calcium a day didn't help my arthritis
in fact it got worse and so what kind of
calcium you taken they said calcium
lactate well there's your problem
because only 250 mg of that is metallic
calcium so let's say you absorb 10% of
that then the other 750 Mig is lactose
or milk sugar so 10% of 250 is 25 so if
you take two of those tablets you're not
getting 2,000 you're getting 50
milligrams so to get what you need you
need to take 90 of those tablets a day
you need to take 30 with each meal and
you got 59 more minerals to
go then there's those people who want to
do things naturally let's see if you can
do anything good with 10 lbs of spinach
and let's be fair let's see if you can
get 1,000 milligrams of magnesium I pick
magnesium because in green leafy
vegetables you have a lot of magnesium
because of the chlorophyll right it's
part of the chlorophyll molecule and any
pound of anything you got 454 gram and
10 pounds of spinach you got 4540 gram
of which most of that 97% is water let's
say you have 1 gram of chlorophyll and
that 10 lb of spinach there's 50 Mig of
magnesium you got to divide that into
the Thousand you want you get a factor
of 20 which you multip Supply times the
10 you have to eat 200 lb of spinach you
got 58 more minerals to
go okay so you got to be a pretty big
person to accomplish all this even as
big as I am you can't get it done so I
prefer to supplement rather than do
those things then of course during the
60s the agricultural industry came up
with teated minerals because Farmers
aren't dumb enough to pay for a dollar
of something that goes into an animal's
mouth and have 99 Cents come out in the
manure I have to really thank farmers
for being that clever and chelated
minerals are just metallic minerals with
an amino acid or protein or enzyme
wrapped around the metal atom and
increase the absorbability to 40% then
the hell food industry jumped on that
right away because it was a major
Improvement in absorbability of minerals
the most efficient way to absorb
minerals is liquid they're very small
particle size are 7,000 times smaller
than a red blood cell and they're
negatively charged so you actually have
an electrical or magnetic gradient that
concentrates these minerals plants have
a very interesting part to play in
colloidal minerals remember we said that
plants cannot create minerals they're
not in the soil plants can't make them
at any rate metallic minerals are taken
up by plants when they're in the soil
plants convert them in their tissues to
colloidal minerals and this is how we
store minerals in our body this is how
we use minerals in our body this is how
we transport minerals from their storage
place to their sight of use in the
colloidal Farm well our plants our crops
don't have much in the way of colloidal
minerals in them because we don't have
any metallic minerals in our soil are
these minerals important You Bet Your
Life they're
[Applause]
important information and statements
regarding dietary supplements discussed
have not been evaluated by the Food and
Drug Administration and are not intended
to diagnose treat cure or prevent any
disease